what's a few tubes welcome back to my
channel Richard on data my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about all things data so in my
first video I talked a lot about what a
data scientist exactly is and the core
components of the work I mentioned
programming is a core essential
component of the work so I want to
expand on that a little bit more so
there's tons of debate about what's the
best tool for your work is it R is it
Python is it Julia sequel gets mentioned
in there a little bit as well and I
think before we even address that
question it's helpful to take a step
back and think about why do we want to
use an open source programming language
in the first place and it's important to
think about both of those parts the open
source part and the programming language
part now in the process I am going to
bash a few tools that other people use
for analytics and for data science and
that's fine because every tool does have
some role and some use somewhere but
there is a reason why R and Python are
the undisputed juggernauts of the data
science world right now so before I get
into all this I would appreciate if you
smash the like button also hit the
subscribe button and hit the
notification bell so YouTube notifies
you whenever I upload a video all right
so if you were asking me to be straight
with you and tell you why you should use
a programming language instead of let's
say a simpler tool like a Microsoft
Office product Word Excel something that
everybody knows I would boil this down
to one simple word and that's
reproducibility to have the highest
quality work possible you need to be
able to start from your raw data and
then look at your outputs that output
could be anything it could be a cleaner
other set of data it could be a report a
model a visualization but you need to be
able to tell that story you need to be
able to see exactly how you got from
that first point your raw data to your
end point which is whatever that output
eventually is that's super important
both for you and for the people that
your work
with first of all if you think you have
a perfect memory I assure you you don't
you are eventually going to have to
revisit your work at some point and it
could be for documentation purposes it
could be to add on to it but you're
going to have to go back to work that
you did in the past and you're going to
forget how or why you did something and
when this happens the fact you wrote
code in the first place is kind of a
safeguard for you because that code is a
paper trail it tells a story and it will
tell you exactly how you got from point
A to point B similarly a lot of data
science work involves collaboration with
team members so suppose you're using a
version control system like github users
can check out your code they can review
it and add feedback to it they can just
get educated and learn from what you did
they can take a project from you and
build on it and write code on top of
what you've already done
possibilities are endless and at the end
of the day writing code in the first
place is what makes that collaborative
ecosystem possible it's also important
to be able to leverage the power of
repeatability because let's be real here
every day at your job is not going to be
completely unique you're going to end up
repeating certain things quite a lot of
times now there are tons of examples of
things that you can end up repeating it
could be cleaning your data based on
some kind of business rule it could be
extracting labels from data sets
it could be removing outliers based on
whatever business rule you came up with
that's unique to your data set whatever
you get the idea there are tons of
things that you may want to repeat now
what's gonna happen if you're writing
code in a nice proactive fashion is
these things which you're repeating over
and over again you can turn those into
functions now functions are pretty cool
because there's a number of ways that
you can share them with other people but
they're really nice for you to because
they almost take on a little bit of a
snowball effect now what do I mean by
that so let's say you're working on a
longer
tasks say it's something which takes
like two hours well once you're done you
can wrap all of that inside of a
function now if you have to do the exact
same task in the future maybe on another
data set maybe on another project you
can just apply that function you've
already written or at least extract
parts of it and then instead of
something taking two hours it'll take
like five minutes instead this ends up
freeing up a lot of your time so you can
end up doing more with the time that you
have maybe you want to write even more
functions automate even more tasks then
you can free up even more of your time
to do even more awesome stuff
possibilities are endless so when it's
all said and done learning a programming
language is not always easy and any
language that you're gonna learn is
going to come with some amount of a
learning curve but I promise you that if
you stick with it you get good at a
programming language apply what you've
learned in the real world write code
proactively with functions you'll end up
saving a ton of time in the long run
because you don't have to reinvent the
wheel and you end up being able to do
more work with less time invested so I
hope I've been able to impress upon you
the advantages of using a programming
language now let's talk a bit about the
advantages of using a programming
language that's open source so for those
of you who are unfamiliar with the
definition of an open source piece of
software there's a lot of things which
go into that definition but the key
parts are these number one it has to be
freely available number two the source
code of something that's open source has
to be freely readily available to the
public and then number three users have
to be able to in some way shape or form
publish their own modifications or
enhancements and now not all industries
necessarily change that quickly but data
science as a field is constantly
evolving as people develop new and
better technologies there's constantly
new features with visualizations that
are available there's new models there's
new
machine learning techniques and it's
super useful to be able to leverage the
newest latest greatest technology that's
out there that's created by big vibrant
user communities and if you take some of
the big open-source programming
languages now like are like Python
Julia's are really big up-and-coming one
they all have really large user
communities which are constantly
developing new packages here's the real
beauty of this I harp away in almost all
of my videos about what a creative field
data science really is you constantly
need to flex your creative muscles and
come up with innovative solutions here's
the thing though honestly when we run
into some problem that's almost never
the first time anybody out there has
ever run into that same problem somebody
out there has probably solved it before
and then developed some kind of solution
for it and that solution it could be
something small like a little function
or it could be a bigger package which is
really just a bundle of functions I've
had it happen to me personally where I
was fishing around on github and I found
this function that somebody else wrote
which would customize a graph just so
happened exactly the way that the client
I was working with wanted it so that way
I didn't have to spend a lot of time
writing the entire thing from scratch
myself then similarly there was another
time I was working with discrete events
and the interactions between them and I
needed to simulate that somehow well
turns out on cran there's a full hour
package that's developed for those types
of problems so when you're working with
an open-source programming language
there's almost always some kind of
solution out there which somebody else
is built you can stand on the shoulder
of giants but if it's not out there you
do have the flexibility to hopefully
quickly build whatever it is that you
need now I do have to point out just as
a disclaimer there are certain companies
which are definitely going to be set in
their ways they're going to use other
technologies let's say SAS spss things
like that which are a little bit older
maybe a little bit more trusted and
there's a variety of read
that could happen the company may have a
large enterprise scale license it just
may be an older and more trusted thing
for them there may be security concerns
with their data it could be for any
reason there's not always a lot that you
can do about that because that could be
a large tide to go up against and not
maybe even something you want to go up
against
I do hope though that this video has
given you some food for thought and at
least makes you aware of some of the
things that your company or your team is
missing out on maybe you can make the
case for our Python or figure out the
way a language like that could be used
to complement in conjunction with
whatever technology it is that your
company uses today now there are
actually more and more examples of
integration between these open-source
technologies and other services so just
as some examples in power bi you can
write R and Python scripts in there in
Microsoft sequel server in the 2016
version and later there's actually built
in our services in there so there are
options like that out there you have to
navigate your own individual case and
find the best thing for your particular
circumstances and your particular
company but once you pick up and get
good at an open-source programming
language you are on the road to going
out there and do an awesome data science
work so thanks for watching this video
until next time Richard on data